[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
hallo und guten Abend ihnen allen an
einem Tag an dem man sich die Augen
reibt ob der deutschen corona-politik
nichts Neues werden Sie vielleicht sagen
und in der Tat es hat ja einiges an
Chaos gegeben in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren und exakt da schließt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt an
vorgestern hatte er nach Beratungen mit
seinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den
Bundesländern verkündet wer infiziert
ist muss ab 1 Mai nicht mehr zu Hause
bleiben die Isolation gelte dann nur
noch freiwillig das Prinzip
Eigenverantwortung gestern nimmt er
alles wieder zurück in der Talkshow von
Markus Lanz und per Tweet um 2:37 Uhr
Christiane hübscher über das Hin und Her
das Karl Lauterbach
der Druck ist zu groß geworden am Mittag
zieht Karl Lauterbach seine umstrittene
Entscheidungen zur nichtisolation von
corona-infizierten auch offiziell zurück
um das war ein Fehler für den ich auch
persönlich verantwortlich bin und das
war eine Fehleinschätzung den
eigentlichen Rückzieher aber macht der
Minister schon am späten Abend
ausgerechnet in einer Talkshow ich
glaube dass das zwar den
Gesundheitsämtern helfen würde dass der
symbolische schaden aber Corona ist
nicht mehr so gefährlich so verheerend
ist dass man diese isolationsordnung so
nicht machen kann also diesen Punkt den
werde ich wieder einkassieren und
schickt dann mitten in der Nacht noch
einen social-media-tweet hinterher in
dem er schreibt hier habe ich einen
Fehler gemacht im Gesundheitsausschuss
lässt sich Lauterbach am Morgen nicht
blicken andere müssen sich dort für ihn
erklären
insofern bitte ich auch da im Sinne der
Kolleginnen Kollegen aus der Koalition
um Entschuldigung das ist kein gutes
kommunizieren ein Rücktritt habe er
nicht gedacht so der Minister doch die
seltsame Fehlerkultur des Karl
Lauterbach provoziert sofort wieder
Kritik aus den Ländern sogar der eigenen
Partei wenn man das einfach perorderte
move stehender Talkshow verkündet dann
lässt das ja die Länder im Regen stehen
und verunsichert die Bevölkerung und das
ist schon eine kommunikative
Fehlleistung die Menschen erwarten auch
in dieser Phase der Pandemie Klarheit
und Verlässlichkeit und dann ist
natürlich nicht gut wenn Politik in
Talkshows und nachts bei Twitter
verkündet wird das ist nicht richtig so
und schon morgen droht Lauterbach im
Bundestag die nächste pleite sein
Herzensprojekt die Impfpflicht könnte
hier durchfallen weil sich keine
Mehrheit für die Impfpflicht für alle
abzeichnete wurde hektisch ein
Kompromiss gefunden der einzige
Gesetzentwurf sieht nun den Nachweis ab
Oktober für alle ab 60 vor mit
Beratungspflicht und Aufbau eines
impfregisters die Impfpflicht für alle
ab 18 könnte im Herbst folgen ich gehe
davon aus dass wir die Impfpflicht
morgen beschließen werden der
Kompromissvorschlag der sich in den
letzten Tagen hier entwickelt hat ist
aus meiner Sicht ein guter Vorschlag
doch so sicher ist das nicht die
Abstimmung sollte eigentlich zur
Gewissensentscheidung werden aber die
unionsfraktionen blockiert schreibt
heute an all ihre Abgeordneten einen
Brief darin heißt es nehmen sie an allen
Abstimmungen teil stimmen Sie unserem
Antrag zu lehnen sie die übrigen
Vorlagen ab für die FDP ein klarer Fall
von Fraktionszwang hier wird klar
festgelegt so müsst ihr euch entscheiden
und nicht anders sonst folgt hier nicht
der Fraktionsdisziplin und ich sage es
hier dass hier leider etwas verpasst
wurde was eigentlich gut wäre für unsere
parlamentarische Demokratie eine offene
Debatte über Parteigrenzen hinweg und
Karl Lauterbach könnte morgen abend noch
ein Problem mehr haben
und hier ist der
Bundesgesundheitsminister guten Abend
Karl Lauterbach guten Abend Herr Sievers
einiges an Fragen bleibt noch Herr
Lauterbach warum gestern Abend die Rolle
rückwärts einen Tag nachdem sie etwas
gemeinsam beschlossen haben mit den 16
Gesundheitsministern der Länder das was
sie jetzt als Begründung dafür anführen
das ist ja nicht neu das haben sie auch
vorgestern schon gewusst oder zumindest
hätten das Wissen können
die Reaktionen in der Bevölkerung hat
mir gezeigt dass die Regel hier falsch
wirkt die Menschen hätten das Signal
vernommen dass es hier eine Lockerung
ist die wir beschließen oder dass es
darum geht dass Corona nicht mehr so
gefährlich ist dass wir in eine andere
Form von Umgang mit Corona kommen und
das wäre das falsche Signal gewesen
außerdem war die Regelung nicht wirklich
sicher für die Bevölkerung von daher
eine unsichere Regel abzuräumen ist die
Aufgabe des Gesundheitsministers auch
dann wenn Sie im Konsens mit den Ländern
beschlossen wurde vor zwei Tagen haben
sie allerdings noch gesagt die Regelung
funktioniert
zwar die jetzige ist aber dauerhaft
nicht notwendig und deswegen können wir
sie abschaffen und ändern was sie jetzt
natürlich erreicht haben Herr Lauterbach
ist einiges an Konfusion auch in der
Bevölkerung sie haben gestern Abend
gesagt das werde ich wieder einkassieren
jetzt ist das ja eine einschneidende
Regel die potenziell jede und jeden in
Deutschland betreffen könnte das Wort
einkassieren das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen nach Gutsherren Art nach dem
Motto ich überlege mir heute was und
morgen kassiere ich dann einfach wieder
ein schafft denn sowas Vertrauen der
Begriff ist hier vielleicht nicht
optimal aber es geht darum folgendes zum
Schluss müssen wir Regeln haben die
funktionieren diese Regelung hätte dazu
geführt dass es möglich gewesen wäre
dass infizierte ohne die
quarantäne-regel zu beachten oder
isolationsregel zu beachten zum Beispiel
weiter zur Arbeit gegangen werden und
das ist dann keine gute Regel und wir
haben das gemacht um die
Gesundheitsämter zu entlasten aber es
ist einfach nicht wert es gibt das
falsche Signal daher muss man dann auch
auch in der Lage sein dass wieder
wegzunehmen und das versteht ja auch
jeder es bleibt jetzt dabei derjenige
der infiziert ist der muss in Isolation
okay das ist keine gute Regel sagen sie
das versteht jetzt jeder sie haben den
Vorschlag zurückgenommen gestern Abend
beim Kollegen Markus Lanz hier im ZDF
das zeigt natürlich zum einen es ist
immer spannend dessen Talkshow zu gucken
auf der anderen Seite stellt sich aber
ein bisschen die Frage warum gibt es
überhaupt treffen Fachtreffen von
Experten Ministerinnen Ministern wenn
sie dann hinterher einfach mal im
Fernsehen ihre Meinung ändern ich habe
meine Meinung nicht im Fernsehen
geändert sondern ich hatte tatsächlich
schon also am Nachmittag also als sie
als ich meine eigene Position verändert
hat da hatte ich das schon also
in den politisch relevanten Gremien
hatte ich das schon mitgeteilt ich hatte
das zum Beispiel also auch dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Rolf Mütze nicht
mitgeteilt oder auch im
Kabinettsmitgliedern ich hätte es heute
morgen ja das habe ich auch gestern
Abend angekündigt also ich hätte es
heute sowieso breiter erläutert und
verteidigt aber wenn ich abends in einer
Talkshow genau zu dem Thema gefragt
werde da kann ich doch nicht
verschweigen was ich am nächsten Tag
öffentlich verkünden werde und zwar hat
der Zufall dass ich an dem Abend in der
Talkshow war nach langer Zeit mal bei
Markus Lanz hat genau
verständlicherweise danach gefragt und
da muss ich doch war da muss ich doch
wahrhaftig und ehrlich antworten Herr
Lauterbach lassen Sie uns noch
inhaltlich auf jeden Fall über diese
neue alte Regel jetzt reden wer sich
krank fühlt bleibt zu Hause geht zum
Arzt das ist ja so wenn man den groben
Zügen ist umschreiben möchte das Prinzip
der Eigenverantwortung das ja jetzt auch
in Deutschland gelten soll diese Pflicht
zur Isolation die haben auch andere
Länder aufgehoben Spanien England
Schweden Norwegen warum trauen sie denn
der eigenen Bevölkerung nicht auch über
den Weg das hat ja nichts mit Misstrauen
zu tun sondern das kommt darauf an wie
vorsichtig man sein will in der
Bekämpfung der Pandemie wir müssen
besonders vorsichtig sein weil wir einen
hohen Anteil älterer Menschen haben wir
haben einen hohen Anteil ungeimpfter
Menschen und wir haben auch bisher immer
vorsichtig das ganze gehandhabt das ist
auch der Grund weshalb wir im Vergleich
zu vielen der Länder die Sie gerade
genannt haben eine niedrigere
Sterblichkeit haben das ist immer der
Kurs für den ich auch persönlich stand
ich habe immer versucht die Regeln so zu
gestalten dass wir möglichst weniger
Sterbefälle haben ohne dass wir die
Freiheit der Bevölkerung zu stark
einschneiden und die den Kurs will ich
weiter verfolgen und dazu hätte die
Regel hier nicht gepasst lassen sie uns
Herr Lauterbach noch schnell bitte über
die Impfpflicht reden auch wichtiges
Thema im Parlament jetzt morgen sie
wollten erst keine Impfpflicht haben sie
kategorisch ausgeschlossen dann haben
sie gesagt ach eine ab 18 da stehe ich
jetzt voll dahinter jetzt kommt wenn
überhaupt eine Impfpflicht ab 60 und
auch da soll im Sommer noch mal
nachgeguckt werden ob sie überhaupt
nötig ist die Kriterien sind
noch relativ unklar warum sagen Sie bei
dem ganzen Thema nicht gleich die
Impfpflicht ist gescheitert die Pflicht
ist nicht gescheitert ich glaube und
hoffe dass wir morgen die Impfpflicht
beschließen werden ich gehe sehr davon
aus ich glaube dass die sagen mal
vernünftigen im Parlament sich dadurch
setzen werden ich will auch noch mal
sagen die Meinung als ich verändert ja
wenn die wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse
sich verändern dann muss auch die
Meinung sich verändern am Anfang hatten
wir Varianten die waren noch nicht so
ansteckend wie jetzt da wäre man
möglicherweise mit Isolationen und
Quarantäne ohne eine Impfpflicht
durchgekommen aber das ist ja keine
aktuelle Position von mir sondern ich
bin stabil seit wir diese besonderen
Varianten haben diese gefährlich sind
immer für ein impfpflich gewesen ich
sage auch dass die Impfpflicht ab 18
besser gewesen wäre als eine impfliche
ab 60 aber die Impfpflicht ab 60 die wir
wahrscheinlich morgen beschließen sie
ist ja auch nur eine erste Stufe damit
schützen wir 90 Prozent derjenigen die
wir mit der impflicht ab 18 geschützt
hätten und ab 18 kann auch noch kommen
wenn bis zum Herbst nicht die
Impfbereitschaft gestiegen ist sagt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach ich danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir vor einer
Stunde aus Termingründen aufgezeichnet
liebe deine Ukraine liebe sie in
grausamen Zeiten und in den letzten
schwierigen Momenten der Vers steht auf
dem Sockel eines Denkmals des
ukrainischen Nationaldichters Terras
chefchenko auf dem zentralen Platz von
borod Janka einer Kleinstadt 40
Kilometer nordwestlich von Kiew die
Büste des Dichters hat Einschusslöcher
aber sie steht noch drumherum allerdings
sieht es so aus Brot Janka ist völlig
verwüstet manche Häuser sind komplett
verschwunden in anderen klaffen Löcher
nichts ist mehr dort wo es hingehört
Borg jankas Einwohner haben ihr zu Hause
verloren und Sie haben schreckliches zu
berichten
Katrin Eigendorf war heute dort Katrin
guten Abend was hast du von den Menschen
dort gehört
ja guten Abend Christian wir waren in
baradianca und hatten da Gelegenheit mit
den Einwohnern zu sprechen das war
wieder eine geführte Tour die
veranstaltet wurde vom ukrainischen
Innenministerium die uns dorthin
gebracht haben und ähnlich wie auch in
Butcher haben die Menschen uns davon den
Gräueltaten der russischen Soldaten
berichtet sie haben uns erzählt dass die
Soldaten mit ihren Panzern durch die
Straßen gefahren sind dass sie auf die
Häuser gefeiert haben eine Frau hat mir
berichtet dass ein Soldat auf sie
zugekommen ist und ihr Mann eine ein
Gewehr an den Kopf gehalten hat und
gefordert hat das Auto zu geben sie hat
es dann in Tränen ausgebrochen und hat
ihn angefleht ihren Mann leben zu lassen
eine andere Frau hat uns berichtet wie
der Sohn einer Freundin auf offener
Straße hingerichtet wurde von russischen
Soldaten das sind die Geschichten die
die Menschen uns dort erzählen das
Ausmaß der Zerstörung was dort erlebt
haben ist um vieles größer als das was
wir in Butcher gesehen haben aber es ist
natürlich noch mal eine zusätzliche
Bestätigung das Butcher kein Einzelfall
ist
schreckliche Erzählungen die man da hört
jetzt gibt es heute noch Meldungen über
viele Vermisste nach wie vor im Großraum
Kiew und es gibt auch dort offenbar noch
Orte in denen überhaupt noch niemand war
in denen es noch keinen Zugang gegeben
hat Katrin heißt das dort dieselben
schrecklichen Entdeckungen befürchtet
werden
damit muss man rechnen was wir heute
erlebt haben ist auch eine gewisse
Überforderung der ukrainischen Regierung
denn und auch der lokalen Behörden wir
haben dort erlebt wie Helfer mit bloßen
Händen versucht haben Leichen aus den
Häusern zu bergen weil nicht das nötige
Gerät vorhanden war wir haben dort
Menschen erlebt die zwischen den
Trümmern herumgeirrt sind völlig
traumatisiert auch gar nicht wussten
wohin und was jetzt mit ihrem Leben
geschehen soll
niemand hat die Lage da im Griff und es
gibt wirklich noch Orte wo die Helfer
noch gar nicht hin vordringen konnten
also ich glaube
Butcher wird nicht die einzige nicht der
einzige Ort sein aus dem diese grauen
berichtet werden sondern der gesamte
Ring hier um Kiew der ja von den
russischen Streitkräften besetzt war
wird wahrscheinlich ein ähnliches Ausmaß
uns zeigen an grolltaten eine Reportage
über Orte an denen sich die ganze gr
Möglichkeit dieses Krieges zeigt ein
Reportage von dir Kathrin gleich im
auslandsjournal herzlichen Dank für den
Moment und Sie können den Menschen in
der Ukraine und auf der Flucht natürlich
helfen hier nochmal die Kontodaten IBAN
de65100
400-600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Nothilfe Ukraine alle Infos auch im
Internet oder im ZDF Text
klar das ist heute viele Fragen gab im
Bundestag an den Bundeskanzler und klar
dass sie sich vor allem um den Krieg in
der Ukraine drehen tut Deutschland genug
gegen Russland für die Ukraine das war
die große Überschrift Waffen Sanktionen
Energie Thomas Reichert gibt den
Überblick
draußen stellen Demonstranten die
Schrecken von Butcher nach drinnen hat
Kanzler Scholz in großen Buchstaben
etwas aufgeschrieben das gewohnt klingt
aber einen Einschnitt bedeutet
es muss unser Ziel bleiben das Russland
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnt das ist das
was hinter den Aktivitäten steht die wir
unternehmen wenn es nun um
Waffenlieferung geht wenn es um
finanzielle und humanitäre Unterstützung
geht wenn es um die Aufnahme der
Flüchtlinge geht oder um die
sanktionspakete die wir global und
weltweit vereinbaren bislang schien es
als hoffe stolz auf ein Einlenken
Russlands auf eine gesichtswarende
Lösung für Putin das Ziel aber Putin
darf nicht gewinnen das ist neu die
Wende kommt nach bitterer Kritik aus der
Ukraine Deutschland helfe zu wenig und
zu langsam die meiste Militärhilfe kommt
bislang aus den USA Gesamtwert über 1,4
Milliarden Euro aber auch das kleine
estland hat mit 222 Millionen mehr
geliefert als Deutschland mit 186
Millionen ich glaube dass es mit dem
politischen mit dem fehlenden
politischen Willen zusammenhängt
insgesamt muss ich leider sagen gibt es
bei der Bundes etwas dass ich bewusster
Halbherzigkeit nenne und die mit der
muss Schluss sein vor ein paar Tagen hat
die Bundesregierung alte DDR
Schützenpanzer aus Tschechien
freigegeben für die Ukraine über die
Lieferung weiterer schwerer Waffen will
die Verteidigungsministerin aber nicht
sprechen und das ist
kein ratische Hürde
ganz wichtig
die Nato und Deutschland darf nicht
riskieren selbst zur Kriegspartei zu
werden die Sorge vor den Kriegsfolgen
führt Deutschland das Projekt auch die
Frage der Sanktionen gegen Putin die nun
ein bisschen verschärft werden sollen
dazu gehören einfuhrverbote für Kohle
dazu gehören transaktionsverbote gegen
wichtige weitere russische Banken ein
weiteres Einfrieren von Vermögenswerten
das ist jetzt ein winziger Schritt Kohle
macht nur 4% der russischen
Energielieferung nach Europa aus wenn
wir die russische Kriegswirtschaft
empfindlich treffen und im Regime die
finanziellen Ressourcen für den Krieg
entziehen wollen dann müssen wir auch
weitergehen in Richtung Öl und Gas
embargo das Massaker von Butcher
verändert etwas in Berlin das Ziel Putin
darf nicht gewinnen bedeutet die Ukraine
muss gewinnen das wird folgen haben beim
neuen Waffenlieferungen und Sanktionen
[Applaus]
und dann die Europäische Union mit einer
mittlerweile fünften Sanktionspaket
guten Abend Anne gelinek da sollen jetzt
zum ersten Mal auch Energielieferungen
betroffen sein nicht Gas nicht Öl
sondern Kohle die große Frage ist ab
wann
ja man muss sich das so vorstellen dass
die EU-Kommission dieses fünfte
Sanktionspaket eigentlich schon
ausgehandelt hatte als die schrecklichen
Bilder aus Butcher bekannt wurden und da
hatte man das Gefühl das was wir bis
jetzt vorschlagen reicht nicht aus und
so kam ein etwas eiliges Kohle embargo
in den Vorschlag die EU-Mitgliedstaaten
hatten heute zum ersten Mal die
Gelegenheit sich diesen Vorschlag
überhaupt anzusehen und Deutschland und
Österreich haben sofort eine
dreimonatige Übergangsfrist in diesen
Vorschlag hineinverhandelt das heißt
drei Monate lang noch dürfen laufende
Verträge bedient werden in der Zeit kann
man sich nach Ersatz umsehen das klingt
jetzt so wie eine Sanktion mit
Verzögerung aber sie ist doch politisch
enorm wichtig weil sie sendet einmal die
Botschaft an Putin pass auf wir gehen
auch an die Energielieferungen heran und
sie sendet eine Botschaft auch innerhalb
der EU und sagt es gibt keine
Denkverbote mehr seit Butter auch ein Öl
embargo muss möglich sein und es gibt
viele Mitgliedstaaten die glauben dass
die Abwehrhaltung Deutschlands
Österreichs und Ungarns nicht mehr sehr
aufrecht zu erhalten sein wird
interessant politisch auf jeden Fall ein
Zeichen finanziell nicht ganz so vier
Milliarden von 100 Milliarden Einnahmen
würden für Russland wegfallen bei der
Kohle was ist an diesem fünften
Sanktionspaket dann wirklich
durchschlagend
es gibt ein paar herausragende Signale
würde ich sagen das eine ist zum
Beispiel dass die beiden erwachsenen
Töchter von Wladimir Putin auf der
Sanktionsliste stehen dahinter steht die
Vermutung dass natürlich Wladimir Putin
sein Geld nicht in eigenem Namen anlegt
sondern eben es verteilt auf Familie und
Freunde einer der Freunde ist auch der
Oligarch Allee der die Pasca der mit
Aluminium reich geworden ist und jetzt
Waffenfabriken besitzt und Putins Krieg
beliefert und das zweite Signal ist die
Einschränkung des Schiffsverkehrs und
des lastwagenverkehrs damit wollen die
Europäer den der russischen Regierung
zeigen dass es eben keine Schlupflöcher
gibt sondern dass man ernst macht damit
Schiffsladungen und waren zu überprüfen
und eben keine Schiffe mehr in
europäische Hafen einlaufen zu lassen
morgen früh setzen sich die 27 Vertreter
der Mitgliedsstaaten nochmal zusammen
und man geht davon aus dass das
Sanktionspaket dann durchgewinkt wird
unsere europakorrespondentin Anna
herzlichen Dank nach Straßburg
und mehr zum Thema in der Übersicht die
hat Hanna ja und da Christian blicken
wir zuallererst auf das Treffen der
nato-außenministerinnen und Minister in
Brüssel da geht es um weitere
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine und um
die Frage ob diese auch schwere Waffen
umfassen sollten die sich zum Angriff
eignen ein weiteres Thema ist die
Erhöhung der Militärpräsenz in den
östlichen Bündnis starten zum Auftakt
warnte Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
dass der russische Angriffskrieg noch
Monate oder sogar Jahre dauern könne das
gelbe einen dringenden Bedarf an
weiteren Waffenlieferungen
jahrelang wurde diskutiert nun soll die
Bundeswehr erstmals mit bewaffneten
Drohnen ausgestattet werden zum besseren
Schutz der Soldatinnen und Soldaten der
Verteidigungsausschuss des Bundestags
stimmte der Anschaffung von insgesamt
140 Kampfdrohnen des israelischen
Modells Heron TP zu die Kampfdrohnen
dürfen allerdings nur dann eingesetzt
werden wenn dies explizit im
Bundestagsmandat für den jeweiligen
Auslandseinsatz vorgesehen ist
nach bundesweiten Razzien gegen Neonazis
hat Innenministerin ferser von einem
harten Schlag gegen die
rechtsextremistische und
rechtsterroristische Szene gesprochen
mehr als 800 Polizeibeamte durchsuchten
61 Objekte in elf Bundesländern die
Aktion richtete sich gegen mehrere
militante neonazi-netzwerke vier Männer
wurden festgenommen insgesamt ermittelt
die Bundesanwaltschaft gegen 50
mutmaßliche Rechtsextremisten
Schüler Auszubildende und Studierende
die Bafög empfangen sollen ab dem
Wintersemester mehr Geld bekommen das
hat das Bundeskabinett beschlossen die
Ausbildungsförderung für Studierende
soll beispielsweise um 5% steigen
außerdem will die Bundesregierung die
Zahl der Bafög-Empfänger erhöhen deshalb
sollen verschiedene Freibeträge
angehoben werden der für das eigene
Vermögen soll zum Beispiel auf 45.000
Euro steigen nun müssen Bundestag und
Bundesrat über den Gesetzentwurf
entscheiden
in Israel hat die Regierung von
Ministerpräsident Bennet überraschend
ihre knappe Mehrheit im Parlament
verloren eine Abgeordnete der
Regierungspartei Yamina hat die
Koalition verlassen angeblich wegen
eines Streits über Speisevorschriften
während des bevorstehenden passages dann
nun weder das Regierungsbündnis noch die
Opposition um den früheren
Ministerpräsidenten Netanjahu eine
Mehrheit haben könnte es zu Neuwahlen
kommen israel hatte in den vergangenen
zwei Jahren bereits vier Mal ein
Parlament gewählt
ein osterpaket hatte Energie und
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck uns
schon angekündigt da war er gerade mit
einer ersten Bestandsaufnahme durch und
hatte festgestellt Deutschland dümpelt
dahin beim Ausbau erneuerbarer Energie
mit dümpeln soll jetzt Schluss sein ob
die Regierung ihr Ziel schafft in den
nächsten 13 Jahren praktisch komplett
umzusteigen auf Sonne Wind und Co ist
alles andere als ausgemacht wie sie das
schaffen will hat sie heute dargelegt
auf hunderten Seiten es ist das
osterpaket und es hat jetzt neue
Dringlichkeit bekommen weil die Wände in
der Energiepolitik nicht mehr nur eine
Frage des Klimas ist sondern auch der
nationalen Sicherheit Karl Hinterleitner
Harry Neumann ist wütend hier im
Westerwald engagiert sich der Aktivist
seit Jahren für den Naturschutz im
Prinzip ist er für erneuerbare Energien
aber die artenschutzregel zu lockern und
seinen Wald mit immer neuen Windrädern
vollzustellen das findet er den falschen
Weg
wir brauchen natürlich einen schlüssiges
Konzept für eine Energiewende die wir
natürlich brauchen
aber das kann nicht so sein dass die
Energiewende oder auch der Klimaschutz
auf Kosten des Natur und des
Artenschutzes und vor allen Dingen auf
Kosten des
biodiversitätsschutzes stattfindet denn
im sogenannten osterpaket spielt
Artenschutz keine große Rolle es geht um
eigenständige Energieversorgung es geht
um Unabhängigkeit von Russland und es
geht in Zeiten des Krieges immer auch um
Sicherheit im Mittelpunkt dieses Paketes
steht eine Formulierung die in Zukunft
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien vor
allem und zur Wind deutlich erleichtern
und beschleunigen wird und es ist die
Formulierung dass der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien im überragenden
öffentlichen Interesse sind und dem
Sicherheitsinteresse und damit der
Sicherheitspolitik Deutschlands dienen
die Ziele des Pakets bis 2030 soll 80%
Stroms aus erneuerbaren kommen bis 2035
fast 100%. außerdem sollen sich auf zwei
Prozent der Landesfläche Windräder
drehen der Teufel stickt dabei wie immer
im Detail sprich bei der Umsetzung vor
Ort am Ende wird es ja darauf ankommen
dass die Länder und die Kommunen vor Ort
die Flächen finden die am besten
geeignet sind für erneuerbare Energien
und wenn diese Flächen nicht gefunden
werden weil sich Länder nicht auf Ziele
einigen können weil einige Länder weiter
an künstlich erhöhten abstandswerten zum
Beispiel zu Windkraft festhalten dann
wird es nicht gelingen das Ziel auf
Bayern hier gilt die zehnfache Höhe
eines Windrades markiert die Entfernung
zum nächsten Wohngebiet flächendeckende
Ausbau wird so verhindert die bayerische
Politik will das bis auf Ausnahmen auch
nicht ändern und kritisiert das
osterpaket entsprechend es wird
einseitig auf den Wind gesetzt und es
wird auch zu wenig für Sonne getan das
heißt es bleibt an vielen Stellen auf
halber Strecke stehen
wirtschaftsexpertinnen sehen das
osterpaket positiv ist Weise für die
Zukunft in die richtige Richtung es ist
eine große wirtschaftliche Chance wenn
es uns wirklich gelingt die erneuerbaren
Energien auszubauen gerade die
Windenergie hat viele Arbeitsplätze
verloren auch die Solarenergie diese
wird man wiederholen können wenn auch
Unternehmen sich wieder ansiedeln und
gleichzeitig machen wir uns unabhängiger
von fossilen Energieimporten die im
Moment wahnsinnig teuer sind also das
kann wirtschaftlich nur vorteilhaft sein
und zu werden wie im Westerwald wohl in
ganz Deutschland bald neue Windräder
aufgestellt für Artenschützer wie Harry
Neumann ist das ein hoher Preis der
deutschen Energiewende
Anlass für viele Fragen an
Energieminister Harbeck nachher vor
meinem Kollegen Wulf schmiese im heute
journal Update aber erstmal hier bei uns
Hannah die noch mal zurückkommt auf die
wirtschaftliche Lage und jetzt auf
Russland schaut der Kreml hat heute
erstmals seine Staatsschulden nicht den
US-Dollar sondern in Rubel beglichen
insgesamt ging es um knapp 650 Millionen
Dollar oder schließt sich die Frage an
ob Russland einem Zahlungsausfall immer
näher rückt weil rihalla an der
Frankfurter Börse wie genau ist dieser
Schritt heute einzuschätzen die Russen
haben immer mehr Probleme ihre Schulden
mit Dollar und Euro zu begleichen klar
das ist eine Folge der Sanktionen die
russische Zentralbank die dazu
eigentlich in der Lage wäre die ist ja
seit Wochen vom Westen kaltgestellt
jetzt haben die Amerikaner die
Daumenschrauben nochmal angezogen
russische Regierungsgelder auf
amerikanischen Konten sind quasi
eingefroren die dort gebunkerten Dollar
damit nicht mehr verfügbar also einfach
die Schulden mit Bibel bezahlen eher
nicht der Haken daran ist die Gläubiger
akzeptieren die rupe vermutlich nicht
jetzt hat Russland eine Frist von 30
Tagen doch noch Dollar zurückdenken
rauszurücken wenn das nicht passiert ist
das Land technisch Pleite technisch weil
geldtheoretisch genug da aber eben wegen
der Sanktionen nicht verfügbar ist Sinn
der Sache der Kreml soll sich
entscheiden wofür die noch verbliebenen
wertvollen Dollar Reserven ausgibt für
den Schuldendienst oder für andere
Zwecke wie zum Beispiel die Finanzierung
des Krieges was würde denn ein
Staatsbankrott Russlands für den Rest
der Welt bedeuten an den Finanzmärkten
ist der Zahlungsausfall sozusagen schon
einkalkuliert das finanzielle Risiko
scheint aber ohnehin überschaubar zu
sein weil es relativ wenige
internationale Verflechtungen gibt viele
Banken haben ihr Russland Engagement
seit der krim-krise ohnehin schon
heruntergefahren eine neue Finanzkrise
ausgelöst durch Russland damit rechnet
keiner danke Valerie nach Frankfurt
eine Meldung vom Fußball in der
Bundesliga hat Augsburg im Nachholspiel
des 26 Spieltags gegen Mainz mit zwei zu
eins gewonnen die Partie hätte
ursprünglich Mitte März ausgetragen
werden sollen aufgrund von zahlreichen
coronafällen bei den Mainzern war sie
verlegt worden
es gibt eine amtliche Unwetterwarnung
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes vor
orkanartigen Böen für den Westen die
Mitte und den Süden Deutschlands mehr
dazu später in den Wetteraussichten
fehlt noch der Blick auf die Lottozahlen
die lauten 2 19 22 24 29 31 und die
Superzahl 6 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
und damit sagt das gesamte heute schon
mal Team danke für Ihr Interesse wir
wünschen Ihnen jetzt noch einen schönen
Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend Sturmtief nach Sim hat
inzwischen bereits Schottland erreicht
es bringt uns viel Regen und viel Wind
und es sieht morgen über Dänemark weiter
in Richtung Südschweden diesen kräftigen
Regen den merken wir schon heute Nacht
denn er überdeckt schon fast ganz
Deutschland nur ganz im Osten bleibt es
noch trocken das wird eine milde Nacht
mit Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 10 und 5
Grad und morgen ist es ähnlich
temperiert wie heute uns erwarten
Höchstwerte zwischen 8 und 17 Grad und
dazu fällt sehr viel Regen im Nordwesten
gibt es dazu auch kräftige Gewitter und
kräftige Schauer dazu pfeift dieser
starke bestimmische Südwestwind
Höhepunkt des Windes ist wohl morgen
Mittag und dann erwarten uns schwere
Sturmböen zum Beispiel im Thüringer Wald
oder im Harz orkanartige Sturmböen oder
Orkanböen beschränken sich aber wohl auf
die Nordsee und die wogesen und kaum ist
dieses Sturmtief ihm danach Osten
abgezogen kommt zum Freitag schon gleich
das nächste Tief hinterher Ortrud das
bringt nicht so viel Wind aber dafür
viel Regen mit und dann kann es in der
Nacht auf Samstag in den Mittelgebirgen
auch schon wieder schneien insgesamt
können so 60 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter hier im Südwesten
zusammenkommen und in der Nacht zu
Samstag geht der Regen in den
Mittelgebirgen in Schnee über der
Samstag wird deutlich kälter der Sonntag
dann schon wieder freundlicher guten
Abend